Poe’s raven may have endlessly repeated
the word ‘nevermore’, but did that corvid
acutely understand the finality of of death
and the act of mourning?
Quoth the raven...maybe!
Hi everyone!
It’s Natalia for DNews!
Dealing with the loss of a loved one is no
doubt a painful time, but are humans the only
species that mourn their dead?
Recently a female snub-nosed monkey in a Chinese
Nature Reserve was observed to fall ill.
The dominant male in the group remained with
her as her symptoms appeared to grow worse.
At one point the female monkey fell from the
tree and landed on the rocky ground.
As she lay injured, the male was seen examining
her and began to groom her while others began
to do the same.
She eventually died and the group moved on.
Researchers buried the female a kilometer
away and the following day, the group of snub-nosed
monkeys returned.
The male went to the spot when the female
had died only to discover she was not there.
He waited two minutes until he solemnly moved
on with his troop.
Was this monkey feeling grief?
Some scientists argue that assigning commonly
associated ‘human’ characteristics to
animals , like love, grief, and empathy is
anthropomorphizing them, or attributing human
personalities to animals without sufficient
evidence.
However, other scientists don’t see the
comparison of these behaviors far-fetched,
even finding it ‘species centric’ to assume
that these traits can only belong to humans.
Just because a monkey can’t write a sonnet
about their loss, doesn’t necessarily mean
they aren’t capable of empathy!
Barbara J. King, a biological anthropologist
wrote a book specifically about the bereavement
of our animal brethren entitled “How Animals
Grieve.”
In King’s book she details multiple species
that mourn the loss of members of their group,
included a dolphin mother who lost her calf,
a group of elephants mourning their matriarch’s
death, and how a domestic cats wailed for
weeks after the death of her sister.
Although these examples can be considered
anecdotal evidence, King has said that the
database of stories from peer-reviewed sources
of various animal species exhibiting empathetic
behavior is growing which will no doubt aid
in the research and understanding of animal
emotion, including grief.
Some of the best documented animals mourners
are our closest genetic relatives, chimpanzees.
At Cameroon’s Sanaga-Yong Chimpanzee Rescue
Center, a group of chimps were seen gathering
around an older female who had recently died.
She had been a maternal figure to many of
the other chimps at the sanctuary and it appeared
that the group were paying their respects.
Similarly, a deceased chimpanzee at a sanctuary
in Zambia was surrounded by a group of chimps
who gently touched, smelled, and lightly groomed
his body.
Volunteers noted that the chimpanzees were
not only processing his death- they were mourning
their friend.
Chimpanzees mothers who have lost infants
have also been documented on several occasions
carrying their dead offspring around for days-
sometimes weeks.
These mothers appear to care for them and
even try to revive them.
This is possible evidence of these animals
understanding or processing death.
This behavior has also been documented in
gorillas, macaques, and baboons.
Another group of animals that have often been
reported to mourn their dead are corvids.
Corvids, or crows, ravens, magpies, rooks
and jays, and have been observed having makeshift
‘funerals’ for their deceased relatives.
Some have witnessed ravens dropping twigs,
grass, and other ‘offerings’ on the dead.
However, some skeptics assert that these ‘funerals’
may be less about mourning and more about
understanding what ‘felled’ their corvid
comrade.
Was it muuuuurder?
Regardless of their intention, it is again
possible evidence of animals understanding
and reacting to death.
There still is more research needed to truly
understand the emotional lives of animals,
and there is a chance we may never really
know how deeply they feel…
Now that we know how some animals deal with
death, here’s a fascinating video about
how humans both preserve AND learn from deceased
animals while preparing them for museum collections.
What do you think?
Do animals mourn their dead?
Will your cat grieve over your imminent demise
or is Mr. Mittens just counting the days until
he can eat you?
Subscribe to DNews and let us know in the
comments down below.
Thanks for watching!